well tonight we heard from the President
of the United States what was one of the
most single most inspiring challenges to
the country and a list of successes
frankly unprecedented over a two-year
period under his leadership
now the never Trump errs were wrong the
mainstream media wasn't is wrong
Democrats were wrong and two years into
the Trump presidency the state of our
great country our union is incredibly
strong getting better every day
the president has governed as I told you
he would as a conservative he has kept
his promises he listed them tonight he
has upheld the principles that have made
this the greatest freest most promised
prosperous country on earth as those of
us that knew him said he would for Trump
it's not about Republican or Democrat it
is about We the People the United States
of America take a look the decision is
ours to make we must choose between
greatness or gridlock results or
resistance vision or vengeance
incredible progress or pointless
destruction tonight I ask you to choose
greatness the agenda I will lay out this
evening is not a Republican agenda or a
Democrat agenda
it's the agenda of the American people I
ask you to choose greatness an agenda
for America and now we're all reaping
many of the benefits let's watch this in
just over two years since the election
we have launched an unprecedented
economic boom a boom that has rarely
been seen before there's been nothing
like it we have created 5.3 million new
jobs and importantly added 600,000 new
manufacturing jobs something which
almost everyone said was impossible to
do nearly 5 million Americans have been
lifted off food
stamps unemployment has reached the
lowest rate in over half a century
african-american Hispanic American and
Asian American unemployment have all
reached their lowest levels ever
recorded more people are working now
than at any time in the history of our
country 157 million people at work 5.3
million new jobs 600,000 new jobs in the
manufacturing sector alone jobs who were
told we're never coming back the economy
is breaking reddit records and hitting
on all cylinders despite a constant
stream of what is pure hatred from the
hate Trump media their allies in the
Democratic Party look at this new poll
from Rasmussen showing the president's
approval rating at a strong 48 percent
it is no accident halfway through his
first term president Trump's pro-growth
conservative Pro energy low regulation
policies are kicking this country into
high gear and writing America's ship
after what were eight long disastrous
economic years under Obama now we saw
the lowest labor participation rate in
those eight years since the 1970s 95
million Americans out of the workforce
the worst recovery since the 40s and
stagnant GDP growth the only President
never to hit 3 percent that was Obama
instead of imposing strict government
controls new government programs like
his predecessor President Trump unless
the two years now has given power back
to you the American people and he has
opened up freedom and liberty and
unleashed American greatness once again
in two short years the president has
signed a record historic low tax cut
he's ended hundreds of Berta's
burdensome government regulations opened
up oil and natural gas expansion
approved new pipelines we are now energy
independent and the world's largest
producer of oil and natural gas
he has also negotiated
trade deals that benefit America with
Mexico Canada and for the first time in
many years manufacturing jobs are back
with a vengeance and let's not forget
the president nominated and he confirmed
two highly qualified originalist
conservative Supreme Court justices who
will uphold our constitutional values
for decades to come
dozens of other originals federal judges
have also been confirmed the President
signed sweeping new criminal justice
legislation into law little Rocketman is
no longer firing rockets over the Sea of
Japan are hostages a home the remains of
our soldiers from the 50s are now back a
new summit is now scheduled for February
27th in Vietnam China's economy is now
feeling the heat with new trade
restrictions Russia is being held in
check with a series of sanctions the US
Embassy in Israel has been relocated to
Jerusalem something so many other
presidents promised and never delivered
on and Isis on the run needless to say
it has been a very busy and productive
two years now despite this tremendous
success Democrats in attendance at
tonight's State of the Union may seem
pretty miserable grimacing scowling
sitting on their hands refusing to stand
up applaud the historically strong state
of our union you remember after eight
years of Obama's economy
oh we had 13 million more Americans on
food stamps 8 million more in poverty
and now we have 5 million fewer people
on food stamps and many millions out of
poverty and refusing to give President
Trump credit for anything meanwhile what
are the Democrats offering you we the
people higher taxes judicial obstruction
open borders eliminating ice they want
to keep the disaster of Obamacare
endless investigation into the president
and insane quest for impeachment
it is literally part of the party of
hate hate Trump every second every
minute every hour of every day and to
them well we saw this with immigration
we saw the things that they stood for
just a few short years ago hating Trump
is more important than helping the
American people and doing their
job to them that's more important than
what protecting our citizens with border
security that we so desperately need
watch this this is a moral issue the
lawless state of our southern border is
a threat to the safety security and
financial well-being of all America
tonight I am asking you to defend our
very dangerous southern border out of
love and devotion to our fellow citizens
and to our country wealthy politicians
and donors push for open borders while
living their lives behind walls and
gates and guards working-class Americans
are left to pay the price for mass
illegal immigration tolerance for
illegal immigration is not compassionate
it is actually very cruel now think
about this how many in the hate Trump
media or Democratic Party said this is a
manufactured crisis all right the last
two years ice officers they made 266
thousand arrests of criminal aliens
including those charged or convicted
nearly 100,000 assaults 30,000 sex
crimes four thousand murders homicides
that's why well not so long ago former
President Obama he sounded an awful lot
like President Trump as did Schumer as
did many of the Democrats now they
oppose that which they supported just a
couple of years ago you may remember
this we do have to have control of our
borders you've got to say to the
undocumented workers you have to say
look you've broken the law you didn't
come here the way you were supposed to
so this is not going to be a free ride
it's not gonna be some instant amnesty
what's gonna happen is you are gonna pay
a significant fine you are going to
learn English you are going to
you are gonna go to the back of the line
so that you don't get ahead of somebody
who was in Mexico City applying
illegally so president Oh President
Obama they sound alike
so what's change for the Democrats
President Trump is in office oh now they
just opposed him with every fiber of
their being I thought they cared about
dream of dreamers in Dhaka and
furloughed employees hating Trump comes
before protecting the security and the
safety of the American people it comes
with a force spurring economic growth
finding solutions for the dreamers they
talked so much about it was offered to
them the results are sad President Trump
put it perfectly when he tweeted quote
Democrats are becoming the party of late
term abortion high taxes open borders
and crime but tonight
the president is vowing to fight back to
protect the lives of those who are the
most vulnerable a powerful moment let's
take a look lawmakers in New York
cheered with delight upon the passage of
legislation that would allow a baby to
be ripped from the mother's womb moments
from birth these are living feeling
beautiful babies who will never get the
chance to share their love and their
dreams with the world and then we had
the case of the governor of Virginia
where he stated he would execute a baby
after birth to defend the dignity of
every person I am asking Congress to
pass legislation to prohibit the late
term abortion of children
powerful moment and the president also
made it perfectly clear America will
never become now think about this even
Nancy and Chuck had to stand up not sure
that congresswoman Acacio Cortes liked
it we will never become a socialist
country watch this
here in the United States we are alarmed
by the new calls to adopt socialism in
our country
[Music]
America was founded on liberty and
independence and not government coercion
domination and control we are born free
and we will stay tonight we renew our
resolve that America will never be a
socialist country Democrats what were
they offering oh they want a wealth tax
and then they want more death taxes and
maybe a 70 percent income tax maybe a 90
percent one Oh
that'll bring us right back to what
Obama gave us 13 million more Americans
on food stamps eight million war on
poverty the accumulation of more debt
than every other president before him
combined for them it appears just about
political quest for power revenge
government control of energy and health
care in every aspect of your life so
they stay in power but for president
Trump this is much more than politics
it's about preserving fundamental core
principles and keeping the promises he
made to protect this country and oath
that he gave bettering the lives of all
Americans getting government off our
backs unleashing American greatness for
decades and centuries to come using the
principles of freedom and liberty and
capitalism